what about opposites friends why is it
that women would want non-kin
non-partner male compatriots the day
the day preferences that we espouse for
our opposite friends look pretty similar
to our preferences for me opposite
friends might have served as protection
perhaps if you're really aggressive so
we might also be looking for those given
the fact that you had to really scrape
the bottom of the barrel to find a
reason that isn't to do with mating for
women to have male friends I think that
explains one of the reasons why men get
so uncomfortable when their female
partner talks about that male friend
that they've got at work women and men
basically exist in different worlds when
it comes to perceiving what's going on
to see completely different situations
and to actually have an awful lot of
friction in their relationship